evalúa la expresión 5 ya la cuarta menos
ye cuadrada cuando llego a la 3a si es
que donde hay allí sustituimos el valor
de 3 para evaluar la expresión esto
resulta entonces 5 por 3 a la cuarta
menos 3 al cuadrado cada que encuentre
una y sustituyó por 3 cada que encuentra
una y sustituyó por 3 y esto cuánto nos
da para esto recordemos el orden de las
operaciones esto es fácil de recordar
con la palabra pendás vamos a ponerlo
aquí p2p es de paréntesis y es por
exponentes md son por multiplicación y
división que tienen la misma prioridad y
adición y sustracción están al mismo
nivel más claramente lo podemos ver así
paréntesis exponentes multiplicación y
división que están al mismo nivel y
adición y sustracción que están al mismo
nivel también aquí vemos que paréntesis
van primero y después de eso exponencia
acción tiene prioridad sobre las demás
evaluamos los exponentes entonces antes
de multiplicar aquí por estar aquí
calculemos entonces éstas
de 33 elevado a la 1 es simplemente 3
esto es igual a 3 luego 3 elevado al
cuadrado esto es igual a 3 por 3 3 por 3
estrés elevado al cuadrado que es igual
a 9 luego tenemos 3 al cubo 3 al cubo es
3 por 3 por 3 o esto lo podías ver
también como 3 al cuadrado por 3 9 por 3
3 por 39 por 3 27 luego tenemos 3 a la
cuarta esto es igual a tres por tres por
tres por tres y esto es igual 3 por 3 es
igual a 9 3 por 3 es igual a 9 9 por 9
81 esto es igual a 81 veamos entonces
cuánto nos da la expresión
sustituyamos aquí esto es 5
3 a la cuarta 3 a la cuarta es 81 5 por
- 3 al cuadrado 3 al cuadrado es 9 menos
9 y esto cuánto es igual calculemos por
acá 81 por 5 81 por 5 esto es igual 5
por 15 5 por 8 40
esto es entonces 5 por 81 es igual a 405
menos 9 405 menos 10 395 405 menos 9 396
esto es igual a 396 y hemos concluido